mitch keller he was scheduled to go last
night but the pirates decided to start
grace wilson in game one keller gets the
knot in the nightcap oh it always makes
a pitcher's life easier when he's one
one two
that always makes it nice too getting a
first out colton wong who homer to start
the game this afternoon now facing
omar narvaez first and third runner goes
throw down and
got him they go ahead and throw down and
michael perez throws out christian
yelich for the final out in the top of
the first inning newman applies the
quick tag and a big final out third
start for aaron ashby he started three
days ago three days rest actually two
innings against the cubs
did not allow a run you know the rain
delay cut his appearance short only 23
pitches for him did really well as a
starter down into minor leagues two and
three and a 266 earned run average as a
starter in triple a
full counts so hoy park opening up the
bottom half of the first and that's
strike three call
good start to the night for aaron ashby
yeah his cruising speed is a big leaguer
i know it's only been a couple of starts
but a little over 96 miles an hour so he
does have a big league arm for sure
breaking pitch looks good first hitter
always important for a guy like ashby
off to a good start have good feelings
early in the game two balls two strikes
to brian reynolds aaron ashby getting
another starting assignment here tonight
2-2 pitch has bounced over to third i
stopping maria's had the throw for out
number two
nice play by luis playing a good third
base not an easy play he doesn't get up
right away and get rid of it quickly
that's going to be a base hit for
for reynolds
good center gravity by uras and a good
throw to first kind of by half a step
the ball two strikes ashby versus
nagowski and there's a little chopper to
the left side charging at thomas
winning over and it's a zero in the
bottom of the first inning for aaron
ashby but if you say who's the best
defensive center fielder you can make a
real good argument it's lorenzo kane
up the middle
nice scoop castro oh pretty play rodolfo
the 22 year old second baseman turns a
4-3 inning ending double play two hits
one left we're through an inning and a
half first two batters retired a
strikeout and a ground out now william
thomas had an opportunity to go one two
three
in this third inning
i can tell you you remember a lot of
arms ball hit deep to right field off
the top of the fence
adamus into second base he has to hustle
now as defoe played it off the fence
adamus thought that was going out it's a
double off the clemente wall well that's
the gift and curse of the clemente wall
you hit one high enough there's a good
chance it's at least hitting off the
wall this one
stays in that close so a two out double
here's yellets who walks back in the
first nothing nothing third inning
liner to center
reynolds coming on hard here comes the
throw to the plate it's strong oh my
goodness
what a throw brian reynolds get some
more gold glow votes ready there's one
guy you don't want to hit it to in that
situation brian reynolds picked the
wrong guy that is what mvps do brian
reynolds charged that ball and threw out
adamus
by a full step at the plate to end the
inning give that man some applause brian
reynolds wow three and two now on jace
peterson rbi chance four on three two
pitch
peterson a base head into right center
field bobby rounding third he's heading
home here's the throw into second
as the brewers break through rbi single
for chase peterson the first run of the
game how about that sitting back on a
curveball able to make contact not over
swinging and peterson driving in the
first run of the game well he was up in
the count three-and-oh got it to full
and then keller hangs a curveball and
peterson would hit it hard enough into
the outfield no chance for reynolds to
throw abby out on that
had too far to go and the brewers take a
one to nothing lead first run of the
night and runners at the corners here's
lorenzo kane 1-2
bouncing ball to second this has two
written all over
they won't get it kane
got the brewers a run lorenzo kane
busting it up the line
they get just the one out should never
say his two written all over with
lorenzo kane's running he is just flying
down that line and pirates doing a good
job trying to turn the double play but
low able to beat it and the brewers get
another run on the board it seemed to me
like castro took a little bit too much
time flipping that ball underhanded over
to newman if he gets rid of it quickly
and puts something on it they might be
able to turn it know for two with a run
batted in lorenzo kane
in the air foul territory
and look at that and it gives you fair
territory they take each other out thank
you very much they're drifting into foul
grounds hayes and newman they take each
other out and a thank you very much from
lorenzo kane runners at first and second
with one out hey that was crazy
you're talking about one of the best
defensive teams in the big leagues it
looks like newman ran into hayes and
hayes knocked over newman and ball falls
in fair territory that's a much easier
play for the shortstop going back
tougher for the third baseman neither
one of them make it i smoked it said
lorenzo kane he'll take it gotta cash in
on this now two walls no strikes to
rowdy teles
coming over from toronto and a snap
throw and that gets through
it's through nagowski peterson rounds
third he's heading home and the throw
not in time
jase peterson scores as the brewers
capitalize on another defensive mistake
the first one is not going to go down is
an error but it's certainly a play that
should have been made and perez is just
trying to do a little bit too much and
throws it away and jace peterson never
slows down around third base that's that
base running we've been talking about
with this team that ball hit lorenzo
slowed it down a little bit but look at
chase he never slows down and able to
get that foot in there the aggressive
base running by the brewers did not get
lorenzo didn't get anybody i don't think
and by the time nagowski picks it up a
little bit too late good job by the
brewers boys smart baseball some great
hustle we have seen that on display
tonight for the brewers and they now
have a three nothing lead as peterson
scores you got kane at second
and teles drills one deep right field a
no doubter over everything
river shot ferrari teles in the sixth
the big man got absolutely
all of it 400
feats they tell us oh my goodness
he likes pittsburgh he's hit some
monster shots in his ballpark took one
into left center last time the brewers
are in pittsburgh and
this one goes into the river one bounce
bounce down
little river walk there
garcia one for two of the walk
garcia well struck
left field and gone
avi saeel garcia has established a
single season career high
with his 21st home run of the year a
little icy on the cake for the brewers
quickly going to now the pirates catcher
here for the nightcap two-strike pitch
and there's a bouncing ball colt wong
flips to adamus that's one on the first
and that's a double play and the brewers
get a shutout here tonight in pittsburgh
four six three double play to wrap it up
and the brewers in fact do get their
shutout
here tonight six to nothing